hey guys this is Dennis the founder take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of Game of Thrones season
4 episode 6 laws of gods and men so yeah
this is the big law and order episode of
Game of Thrones Oh Jen yeah which we'll
talk about at the end but let's let's
start off with with Stannis and Davos
coming to to Braavos this is the first
time we've got to seen Braavos yeah that
was a great opening shot I love just
seeing like you know the soldier with
the Broken Sword Mark Gatiss made a
great special appearance who plays
Mycroft on Sherlock if you're a fan of
the BBC Sherlock series great actor
making Santis wait until you know
through midday waiting for them to show
up
great scene I mean always loving cuz
Sanus is always so like I'm above
everyone else I like when he's put in
this place and of course you know I love
seeing you know his boy come to his
rescue
Davos yeah that was a great job as
always you know just kind of you know
defending for better for worse well the
thing is is Stannis I mean like Renly
had said and was in the first season
about he it was the first season or
second season whatever
like he's saying like Stannis said he
just doesn't have he doesn't have any
charisma he's no you know he is loyal
he's a man of his word though he is a
man of his word but he's also has a lot
of pride and that's why he couldn't
compromise with Robb Stark's basically
you know they could have won the war
right and now he has too much pride that
he still he doesn't want to like beg the
people of Braavos for money right Davos
has to convince them and say hey look
Tywin's old he's gonna get you know he's
gonna die eventually then what do you
got left right because the whole
question is we who are you gonna back
next they're basically you know their
investment bankers in a way they invest
in who the winning team is gonna be and
you know like he said this war is not
gonna be over as long as Stannis
sorry stainless standing saying those
problems so it was it was a great scene
just well done it was great like I you
know I'm seeing the guy from Sherlock
you know do his thing it was really well
done and with the Braavosi for them
everything is all about numbers and
logic and what's the logical choice what
you know and for them like they have to
be convinced that that Stannis was the
logic yes emotional one but I think
Dallas did a good job especially with
the finger thing kept like
showing them this is the price that I
paid it was fair you know I paid my debt
now I move on I love Davos too he always
defends himself about being a parsec
well actually I wasn't apart the Pirates
at the stealin I helped move the product
Mugler I'm the smuggler I don't do that
and then of course I love Idol the
actor's name I love the guy who plays
Salladhor saan he's great you know
telling that whole pirate story about
the red shirt and the brown pants and
and all that you know with the
prostitutes they're in the bath I was a
great scene you know I loved their
chemistry between Davos and Salvador
same way yeah he's like oh I used to
think this guy loved me I know it is
like hey thank you you're not my friend
my friend so yeah now they got the money
obviously because he talked to him and
showed him you know gave him some of the
money that he owed him grass and said
there's more of it now he's got to go to
war they didn't specifically say what
they're gonna do next it said we're
setting sail and the sunrise or whatever
so now I got to see what move they're
gonna make no and upcoming episodes
all right be good and then the next week
we haven't seen the Theon storyline for
a while and you know Yara starts reading
that letter yes you give what kind like
a Braveheart speech exactly her speech
yeah like basically whatever they're
doing to him they're doing to all of us
whole country bah bah bah but then when
she gets there she finds like well
because she I'm sure she expected him to
be messed up right expecting him to be
tortured messed up he'll be Theon
Greyjoy exactly not completely you know
she couldn't account for someone like a
Ramsay snow
well someone that's like so psychotic
that would do something like to him
right and basically saying okay well
reek there's no Theon anymore it's just
reek yeah yeah it was a good scene I
mean Ramsay you think he you know he
might be a little tired you know Boyd
has had some sex time I don't think he'd
be up to his you know the most visiting
a visceral nature but I mean he was
ready to go this comes in shirt off
bloody ready to fight you know and I
love the question posed gr is like you
know like how fast can you run
and then the accr at the end just kind
of run in towards the ship and so that's
not my brother anymore
getting out yeah wonder if that's gonna
hold if she's truly done with that and
right cuz almost seems too fast like you
stop in and do that then like I'm out
I'm done
and then she was upset because he
wouldn't leave with her he started
yelling Starscream
Ramzi kind of rewarded a bath for him
the scary so boy I don't think that the
best gonna be acid or some type of like
piranha and they're like something bad
even you can just see him shaking like
there's something wrong with that water
well he's he's he's scared of everything
that's why he didn't run off with yara
because he's afraid like oh if i get
caught right i'm gonna just get beaten
up some more you know i was watching the
inside the HBO episode yeah and they
were talking about like he's all about
pain avoidance yeah like he's just his
whole goal is just not to get beat up
yeah and i think it's a it's a good
episode for him because I think even me
I was last season getting tired as
Washington being tortured that's not
really I'll be on something it's great
television just watching this guy be
tortured having his junk cut off and you
know teased by women and you know it's
just it wasn't interesting but now we're
seeing that payoff it was nice senior
come in try to save them it looks like
now rim she's got a plan for him you
know I need you to be Theon and great I
need you to act for me to do something
for me so now we're gonna be able to see
reek
aka Theon Greyjoy do a little something
that was opposed just being tormented
this whole life yeah but I think with
the torturing like it was hard to watch
but then because of how they needed the
character to turn hmmm they needed to
show that cuz otherwise you'd be like
well how did he get to this place I'm
fine with this scene or so but I think
for me this is my opinion I think we saw
it too much last season that's just me
though yeah I think in order to get
across that he's you know cuz if you
just show to torture scene let's say a
season you're not gonna get that that
like oh he's like this he's he's turned
into someone completely different you
know you have to like drive it into
people's heads like no this guy went
through he did yeah we probably it
seemed to pay off for this now yeah and
then also we saw Danny kind of dealing
with parts of the ruling that she
probably didn't expect yeah yeah I mean
she's she's got a he's got a lot of
fronts ability she has 200 and whatever
many people that she has to see on a
daily basis now that I have problems
that I like because in the books Danny's
not really my favorite character she's
so I don't know she's very proud and she
thinks like her ideal she considers
herself to save you're like I'm gonna go
too
seven kingdoms I'm gonna stay here we're
gonna want me to roll they're gonna
desire me to roll and she's very naive
in a lot of ways and I like that this
kind of put her in a place I mean I
don't know who the actors who played the
the the the noblemen who came up and but
that was a great scene that was one of
like for me and I know I got lot of
flack for this last week and I
criticized last week's episode and last
week's episode was not my favorite Game
of Thrones episode I still stand by that
I rewatched it before this and I still
don't think it was on my favorite
episodes being that being said it's
still better than not you're wrong it's
awesome it's still better than 90% of
television out there right now and I do
say that this was my favorite episode of
the season hands on even better than the
purple wedding I think this is my
favorite I thought Bryan cogman is
writing was spot-on the directing was
great and this seems one of my favorite
scenes of the story just because Danny
had to think he's like oh wait not ever
it's not completely transparent
everybody's bad just because this person
had it's like I mean I'm
african-american I don't want me to get
to play I'm african-american
I just slept I'm descended from slaves
in this country in America and not every
slave owner was the worst kind you know
what I mean you told that in 12 years of
slave yeah not every person is the worst
person ever so it's like this guy maybe
he didn't deserve the punishment that he
had you know and I really like that they
addressed issues like that yeah and also
it showed some of the you know the side
of ruling that that isn't so not
glamorous but like she just expected
okay like these people are gonna love me
correct freedom and I punished all these
bad guys not realizing not everyone is
always not everything black and white
right yeah and so by doing that she did
probably do something that she probably
realizes now was not the smartest thing
right she'd go through and be like oh
who's this guy this guy actually opposed
I opposed the thing that all those slave
kids getting killed yeah so he was
actually a good guy if you know the
noblemen if it's true
so she allows him to bury just her
father his mother right not anyone else
his father because she's you know kind
of touched and moved by the story and he
humbled himself he bowed and did all
that it was good and before that was the
whole goat scene yeah that's good to
know we got to see it all all the money
in the Dragon
yeah they they spent all the money
basically for the dragon to come and and
eat the goat right and you know that was
one of those things where like okay she
she's doing something nice yeah for them
it that was kind of an easy thing to do
especially considering like I'm sure she
has more money now her in so it's like
okay here your goats whatever three
times the price of a bunch of goats do
nothing yeah it's not bad
yeah but I don't know how the other 200
something meetings went that those are
great saying yeah yeah what I like about
it it's showing kind of the you know the
hardships of ruling yeah not so cut and
dry easier for Danny like oh I'm just
gonna free slaves yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna be a queen I'm gonna rule like she
says a very epically I'm gonna rule but
then like oh wait I gotta sit here for
like what eight or more hours a day just
listen to people like their problems
exactly yeah no it's not and then now on
to King's Landing where the bulk of the
episode is the law and order the trial
of Tyrion but before we get to the trial
they have a like a council meeting with
Tywin Marjorie's father Prince Oberyn
and Cersei and grand maester pycelle
yeah yeah those those great I love
Prince Oberyn in that scene he's
becoming one of my new favorite
characters I loved he said there was
like all these means gonna be this early
I was out late last night
I love women because he's a prince so
he's a high-ranked little bin Tywin
walks in they all stand up it's over
just kind of sits there and like
whatever whatever I'm a prince I don't
need that and I love Marjorie's dad like
how it's like go get my pen and quick
yeah what we call happy to be there he
was so happy his present matter yeah
doesn't matter what he says or does he's
just happy to be there right right just
I mean I don't know I guess for this
show I think you and I'm probably agree
on this a little bit I love the scenes
with Tywin and just like the small
counts like some of those conversations
are some of the best in the series like
this stuff with bran and Jon Snow is
it's fine but I love the just those
small moments in that council there's so
much tension there's so many different
emotions so much so many things moving
but it's in a subtle way it's no big
deaths there's not a lot of blood or
anything going on it's just very subtle
nuanced moments and I think this show
pulls it off better than most
also one thing - about on the same lines
that you're talking about is I know the
Lannisters are the evil ones right but
they have the most interesting
characters you look at Tywin look at
Cersei look at Tyrion look at Jamie
Lannister know like who's really coming
into his own these are some of the most
fascinating characters I mean there are
other ones as well you know you have
Aria and Dany and some other ones Jon
Snow but like the bulk of the most
interesting stuff that happens with the
Lannisters and I like that they they
keep mentioning Dany they keep
mentioning Daenerys being like look
there's this girl over there and she's
just like well why should we worry about
this girl half a world away they're like
no she has dragon she has these you know
the unsullied and of course you know
various and Prince Oberyn recognized
like hey these are full of old opponents
they could cause damage if they do come
over here and you know I liked islands
like we got to deal with her we got to
do something you know he Tywin smart
enough to know that she will be a threat
eventually when she decides to come over
whatever she decides to do he may he may
be under estimating the Dragons though
yeah he keeps saying baby dragons but I
like how viruses like they grow bigger
each year like you know he said as a
kingdom hasn't been one in 300 years
with dragons but I'm like yeah but the
kingdom was one at one point and he
wasn't around anywhere in this Cersei
kind of brushed it off to you like
whatever who cares about this girl blah
blah blah it's like now it's actually
pretty important because she's building
herself even though Danny is not the
most experienced leader she does have a
loyal following great advisors good
advisors armies you know and Cersei it
was like oh yeah who cares about a
Saracen what's his name better sell me
the the other guy not Mormont like she's
she's like what an old washed-up it's
like not really still I mean I think
it's a problem with Cersei Cersei like
even Tywin said you think you're smarter
than you are she underestimates her
enemies I think an Tyrion said once in
an episode like oh and you over value
money yeah she think she just buy
everything with her looks and her money
she can just get whatever she wants
that's not the case
Tywin smarter than that bearish is much
smarter than that
I loved and then just the scene just
following after I I don't know if you're
good I think
it's over in his kind of replaced little
finger not they're not the same they're
very different but remember they of
those great conversations in the first
couple seasons with varies in
Littlefinger's are looking at the Iron
Throne and it's discussing politics and
you know philosophies and I love now
that Prince Oberyn has kind of moved
into that position now that was a great
conversation between those two yeah but
you still have Petyr Baelish oh you
shall hear yeah and beerus vying for the
right from behind the scenes you know
Petyr Baelish you know moving with
Tyrells and with the whole you know
assassination poisoning of of Joffrey
and then you have Varys here you know
we'll talk about this later but in court
with Tyrion and how he maneuvers with
the Lannisters as well so he's he's
trying to position himself into into
power and yeah you're right the
conversations you know he has with
Oberyn about desire because it's weird
you have this thing where here's a guy
Prince Oberyn who loves men and women
you live in the light living the life
desire it's all where where Varys is
like Oh desire basically sees desires a
weakness so he doesn't like because you
assumed I think early on we made the
assumption that Oh even though he's a
eunuch he probably you know there's at
one point like something yeah well there
was rumors that he like little boys
thing but he's like no I don't like men
or way you know I care about other stuff
yeah that was great now I like to that
we see Oberyn he's smart like I like
that we see the when he said he found
out what accent he had he said you know
you're from this area yes and he said
I've lost my accent completely he's like
well I have a talent for that too and I
really like that those guys I hope we
get to see more conversation over ins
like the wild card you know like you
know what he's saying even though he
took Tywin's deal to be a judge to be in
the small Council we don't really know
what he's got going he's a really good
character yeah yeah I really like him
and so let's finally get to to the trial
you know Tommen decides to recuse
himself that's a little speech you know
from the actor it gets a good job well
you know you figure Tywin probably
talked him into doing it and he probably
didn't want to do it was something that
hit you know
I'm sure that he didn't have to bend his
arm backwards to do right he was like oh
you know this is my uncle he probably
likes his uncle yeah it's like I don't
wanna but at the same time I don't wanna
seem weak what I'll let my grandfather
who everyone respects yeah and fears do
it so he just gets out of there yeah
yeah I mean that was good I mean you
could you can tell like there's no like
malice in his voice when he knows
anything he's just do what you have to
do within the you know I think he looks
at his uncle a little bit and uncle nods
and walks off and then with courtroom
scenes goroutines can sometimes be a
little dull they can drag on too long
this isn't you know The Good Wife that
specializes and things like that so well
they they know that it was a great job
was the grid court was it it was long
but it wasn't too long no and they kept
each person's testimony pretty sure
there wasn't like like a lawyer doing
like a lot well I mean not like the
traditionally like a lot of like back
and forth interrogation it was like you
know good-sized answers get done you
know get in and get out you start off
with that one sir Marin Jerry yeah
basically said oh I saw this stuff
happened so all these things that that
that Tarin had done in the past that we
all kind of applauded him for having
Joffrey seen these cool lines to Cersei
and offering all the stuff now they're
coming back to haunt him right cuz not
like a lot of this stuff I mean
obviously we know that he didn't kill
Joffrey right and and there are certain
things that are being lied about but a
lot of the stuff that they are saying
was true he didn't say those things to
Cersei he did slap Joffrey you did say
those things to Joffrey as well yeah I
mean it's good I mean I like the whole
line of questioning I mean probably the
most interest I mean I guess what's
gonna be on the internet people can talk
about it is Shay but I think the more
interesting testimony for me is various
because varies was the what Shay you
know well we'll talk about that a little
yeah but I got a lot to say about but
yeah you don't know yeah but Varys is
the guy who if anybody who was sticking
up for Tyrion over and over again
it was Varys so it's like I think Tyrion
well he wasn't more heartbroken by by
him but he was very confused he was like
wait a minute why are you he was hurt by
it by Shae and with Vera's but Vera's
was the one that like started it off
yeah and because he felt like okay he
he knows that I am a good guy he knows
that I've done all these good things for
the kingdom right and and that I'm
getting the short end of the stick and
even this guy won't stick up for me
right because then after that before the
Shea stuff we had it's called an
intermission lunch you know any Tywin's
I've eaten lunch they had to take a
break for lunch and you know Jamie's
basically trying to you know barter try
to plead for turians life because I mean
you know I think Jamie I I didn't I wish
we could still see more of Jamie and
Tyrion together I know there's this
trials going on but uh I love the moment
he's trying to flew them like hey can
you give a break it's like no if he
confesses or whatever or no he'll be
found guilty and then we'll go to the
Nights Watch likelike Ned yeah Ned's
deal which of course didn't do well for
now but Tywin is someone that would run
or that deal because he's not Joffrey
because Joffrey's just was a loose
cannon it just does things for his own
pleasure
where Tywin was calculated with this
this was his plan all along he took a
tragedy it's not like he expected this
happen but he's taking a tragedy and
putting it to his advantage which is to
get Jaime to continue the lineage yeah
you know I mean he said quickly like
okay because he knew that that
eventually Jaime would come to him with
some sort of proposal like this but you
wonder in all that I'm not speculating
from any knowledge in the books I'm just
curious from the TV show you wonder if
Tywin knowing let's say let's say Tywin
I mean they're calling all he's witness
since the time one has to know the
witnesses I'm assuming knowing who's
coming out so let's say Tywin O'Shea's
coming out I wonder if he thought that
Tyrion would just go to the wall like I
wonder if Tywin knew like that that
would Shea would break him I don't think
so I don't think so otherwise he
wouldn't have had her called up I think
I think Tywin deep-down knows tiering
didn't do it
yeah you know sure I think Tywin smart
enough to know why would Tyrion set
himself I'm smarter up exactly exactly
but he just for him he's just taking
advantage of the situation where you
know and Jamie you know he said he was
willing to sacrifice so much yeah you
know even though it's like a twisted
warped relationship with Cersei he loves
her Leslie excuse me
it's a sister yeah but like so he's
willing to give that up in his own in
his own mind that's a big deal right and
willing to go move away go take a little
costly rock do all these things he
doesn't want to do save his brothers
save his brother who he's not gonna see
anyways his brothers gonna go back to
the wall just for the fact that he knows
that his brother still alive yeah I mean
I thought that was that's tough and
looks great I mean it's a big sacrifice
it shows how close they are you know I
mean I've you know you and other people
told me in the books there the
relationship between them they show much
closer in the TV series it's they don't
shut up time something exactly they show
bits and pieces but right you know this
shows kind of ultimate sacrifice for
right right yeah I mean those handled
well again the was a good courtroom
scene you know it was good you know not
didn't drag out too long so I mean
intermission they come back and then the
big one yes Shay comes out okay so your
favorite character on game with okay so
this is what happens so after this this
episode errors I get a bunch of messages
on Twitter you know on our YouTube
channel and so I'm sure some of the
people are watching and people are like
huh see I showed you know I told you
she's she has a purpose and shaded this
and blah blah blah and like I my
reaction is actually yes she did have
her character had a purpose but her
being so unlikable and the relationship
and just everything about her that I
don't like right actually hurt this
scene so people are like oh no no she's
this way for a reason no I did I totally
disagree the problem is is okay before
you it wasn't what she was doing you you
weren't the actress the well both both
things you know I think they went hand
in hand I mean the fact is she's just
not likable right in this scene the
problem is is it's supposed to be
heart-wrenching yeah and so because
she's unlikable you just get angry like
okay for the people who aren't fans of
her like me you just get angry you're
like oh I told you so I told you so but
that's not the intent of the scene
intent of the scene is for you to feel
like oh my god tyrians been betrayed by
the one he loves alright like and so
because she you know at least from my
point of view didn't fit that role
mm-hmm then it doesn't work as much
because if let's
it was someone that I was like oh man I
really liked her I like them together I
felt their love this is so
heart-wrenching that that she's
betraying him right how could she do
this but instead it's more like oh
you're so annoying I knew you'd do this
right yeah so that's why it that's why I
still say it didn't work okay no I know
that's essentially that's a great take
cuz I guess I always knew that scene was
coming so it just the suspense for me
wasn't really there in that moment I
just like seeing the performances from
well teary I'm sure not for from Peter
Dinklage's was just like at the end he
was just saying I wish I could kill you
all I give my life to point you know all
that he was great but yeah her that
scene didn't really do much for me even
though I guess I knew it was coming so
there was really not much of an
emotional impact for me there yeah it's
Peter Dinklage's performance is what did
it for know of course I mean that he was
supposed to be so heartbroken over
I mean Varys was the set up in terms of
like oh that cut that hurt him because
it's like I thought this guy was my
friend or somewhat of a friend and on my
side and he knows what I've done but
then this was kind of the final blow
right because this is a woman that he
loved yeah and it's like really like
you're that bitter about what happened
you know if you were smarter you knew
that that he did that for your own good
but yeah who knows I mean I don't know
what's happened behind the scenes I
don't know if they threatened cheese I
don't know if she has family or whatever
the hell I don't remember her back story
because I don't really care about her
character but yeah I just I just found
it
yeah just more annoying than anything
all right I mean then that drives him
just you know such ferocity is just
yelling everybody saying what role and
Jamie had that look he's like no it was
like you're gonna ruin it yeah
everything's falling apart you know and
even of course calls out his sister by
saying you know watching your bastard
boy die was more pleasurable than a
thousand Horde or something like that
and at the end demands trial by combat I
was trying to repeat what happened up at
the Vale yeah when bran helped him out
well he is so sick of the hypocrisy of
the whole thing because he knows he's
not gonna get justice he's not gonna get
justice he knows that he's being
unfairly punished because of who he is
for being a dwarf like he's if he was
like someone else I'm sure he would have
got a lot of props for a saving King's
Landing from the Battle of Blackwater
and he knows that like you know like
they're all praising Joffrey Cersei was
talking in her testimony about like Oh
like you know Joffrey wanted to stay on
the front lines because he wanted to
inspire the troops but it was it was
Tyrion that said no he needs to do this
so basically he's just he's had enough
you know when there's that much
injustice and hypocrisy done to you
specifically and no one sees all the
good that he was trying to do he just
got sick of that up he's like I'm out so
it makes total sense yeah but the
problem is now puts Tywin in a hard
place well that was a great staredown
just watching teary and in Thailand just
stare each other down just like now what
are you gonna do kind of like that kind
of look and then of course you know the
rains of castamere starts playing you
know it seems like that's like the
Imperial March almost of Game Boy it's
their Imperial March so it was good I
mean and now you know he wants to travel
by combat so we got to see what that's
all I guess what's five of the screws up
Tywin's plans oh yeah like okay here
he's gonna mercy we'll send him through
the wall I'll get everything I want from
Jaime right Jaime's not gonna do what
time what he promised know if if Tyrion
dies right yeah then Tywin's plans are
all out the window right and and this
trial by combat throws a wrench into his
plans right so that was good I was
really good this like this is one my
favorite episode is probably my favorite
episode of this season anyway it was
great I think it was well done yeah and
then you know I these aren't big
spoilers if you watch the the on next
yeah yeah you see that whoever the actor
that's coming to be the mountain for the
third time third Mountain after Mountain
actor is gonna come back you know
there's speculation that he's gonna come
back and fight for the during the combat
um and there's speculation on who he's
gonna fight I won't go into that right
right but tyrians gonna you know
hopefully pick a champion yeah or
himself yeah and we'll see who that is
yeah cuz it's not gonna be him cuz he
will die
I can't show ya a short amount of time
mm-hmm it's gonna be yeah it's gonna be
good all right guys so that's what we
thought of this episode you can post
your comments below on the website thank
CARICOM or on our youtube channel think
AeroPro make sure to subscribe to that
you also can find us on Twitter Dennis
and myself for at think here oh I'm
personally a Griffin de anyway yes I
have a Facebook page that's Facebook
there comm slash think hero fans make
sure to like that page and share our
videos on Twitter Facebook and all that
stuff
you